[موسيقى]
نعم ليلى الاوضاع لازالت على حالها من
ناحيه استمرار الغارات الجويه وايضا القصف
المدفعي الذي لا يتوقف على مدار الساعه ل
مختلف المناطق في مدينه خانيونس في ساعه
مبكره من صباح هذا اليوم انسحبت دبابات
واليات جيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي من
المنطقه المحيطه بمستشفى ناصر مع ساعات
الصباح الباكر بعد ان عاثت فسادا ونبش في
عدد من القبور في مقبره خانيونس القريبه
من المستشفى من الجهه الجنوبيه
والمتاخمة شهيدا التوغل الاسرائيلي بدا
بحزام ناري كثيف نفذته الطائرات الحربيه
الاسرائيليه وايضا هذه الطائرات دمرت خمسه
من المنازل بعدد من الصواريخ على رؤوس
ساكنيها ما ادى الى ارتقاء 13 شهيدا
بالاضافه الى اصابه العشرات بجروح متفاوته
وايضا هناك جهود سواء ذاتيه من قبل
مواطنين او من الدفاع المدني لانتشال
جثامين عدد من الشهداء بين ركام هذه
المنازل التي دمرتها الطائ رات الحربيه
الاسرائيليه قبل ان تتوغل اليات ودبابات
جيش الاحتلال الى المنطقه المتاخمه
والمحيط بمستشفى ناصر الطبي من الجهه
الجنوبيه
ايضا قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي نسفت قبل
قليل مربعا سكنيا في منطقه قيزم النجار
يضم عدد من منازل المواطنين في تلك
المنطقه هذه المنطقه ومحيط كليه العلوم
والتكنولوجيا تشهد اشتباكات عنيف ومتواصله
بين المقاومه الفلسطينيه وقوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي منذ ايام وايضا هنا في محيط
مجمع ناصر حيث المقبره التي كانت هدفا
لاليات ودبابات جيش الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي دارت اشتباكات طيله ساعات
الليل كنا نسمع دوي اشتباكات عنيفه وضاره
بين المقاومه قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
وسط محاولات لمنع تقدم قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي اكثر مع ساعات الصباح الباكر
ومع شروق الشمس انسحب
اليات جيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي من تلك
المنطقه وعادت ادراجها الى المناطق التي
كانت على تمركزاتها السابقه خلال الفتره
والايام الماضيه تحديدا في اطراف منطقه
بطن السمين هذه المنطقه على وجه التحديد
تتعرض طيله ساعات طيله الساعات لقصف مدفعي
وغارات جويه هناك العديد من الشهداء في
منطقه بطن السمين وفي قيزان النجار ومناطق
اخرى يصعب على المواطنين وحتى على فرق
الاسعاف الوصول اليه لانتشال جثامين
الشهداء وهذا ما يفسر الارتفاع المضطرد في
اعداد جثامين الشهداء التي تصل الى مستشفى
ناصر كنا نتحدث في ساعات الصباح عن سبع
شهداء ارتفع حتى هذه اللحظه الى 13 شهيدا
تم انتشالهم من المنطقه التي يستطيع
المواطنون الوصول اليها او حتى فرق
الاسعاف الوصول اليها لانتشال جثامين
الشهداء الى جانب العشرات من العائلات
تحديدا في منطقه قيزان النجار لازالت
محاصره منذ ايام داخل منازلها وتتعرض لقصف
مدفعي اسرائيلي والحديث عن شهداء وجرحى
داخل هذه المنازل لا تستطيع طواقم الاسعاف
ولا حتى الصليب الاحمر القيام بتنسيق
لادخال سيارات الاسعاف وفرق الدفاع المدني
لاجلاء هذه العائلات المحاصره وايضا انقاذ
حياه الجرحه وانتشال جثامين الشهداء من
هذه المنطقه في خزان نجاره التي تشهد
اشتباكات ضاريه على مدار الايام السابقه
الوضع هنا يزداد سخونه في مدينه خان يونس
مع استمرار وكثافه الغارات الجويه
الاسرائيليه على مختلف المناطق في المدينه
سواء في قزان نجار منطقه معم خزاعه بن
سهيله عبسان بالاضافه الى منطقه البلد
التي نسفت قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي يوم
امس مساء امس عدد من المربعات السكنيه
وتضم ايضا مباني تجاريه وهذه المنطقه كانت
تعد قبل الحرب الاسرائيليه على غزه عصب
حياء لمدينه خان يونس التي تعد من اكبر
المحافظات في المنطقه
الجنوبيه مؤمن يعني لفت نظري ان يعني حولك
سيارات واضح انها تعمل بالوقود الوقود الى
اي درجه هو متوفر والى اي درجه اصبحت
السيارات الاسعاف تستفيد من هذه
النقطه الوقود هو في شح كبير في المنطقه
الجنوبيه لا يتوفر وقود لجميع السيارات
فقط ما يتوفر هو ماده السولار التي تشغل
فقط سيارات الاسعاف المواطنون يضطرون
لاستخدام دام وسائل بديله مثل الغاز وايضا
ما يعرف بماده السيرج لتشغيل سياراتهم و
في عمليات الانتشال نلحظ قبل قليل انتشل
المواطنون جثامين ثلاثه من الشهداء وصلوا
الى مجمع ناصر على عربه يجرها حيوان
الى المنطقه تم انتشالهم من المنطقه التي
انسحب بها جيش الاحتلال هنا العدد قليل
جدا من ناحيه الطواقم الطبيه وايضا من
ناحيه فرق طواقم الاسعاف وسيارات الاسعاف
التي تعمل بال هناك شح كبير في كافه انواع
المحروقات التي تشغل السيارات وايضا
المولدات الكهربائيه الى جانب النقص الحاد
في المواد والمستلزمات الطبيه والنقص
الكبير في الكوادر الطبيه امام الاعداد
الكبيره التي تصل على مدار الساعه من
الجرحى على مستشفى ناصر على الاقل وهو
الذي يعد المستشفى الاكبر في المنطقه
الجنوبيه وفي قطاع غزه بعد اخراج قوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي مجمع الشفاء الطبي
وهو مجمع الكبير في مدينه غزه عن الخدمه
كل الطاقه الاستيعابيه لاستقبال الجرحى
وايضا الى جانب المرضى هنا في مستشفى ناصر
الذي تحيطه عمليات القصف الجوي والمدفعي
الاسرائيلي و وهذا ما حدث ليله امس عندما
كثفت المدفعيه الاسرائيليه والطائرات
الحربيه من غاراتها في محيطها اضطر عدد من
المرضى واهاليهم وايضا الجرحى الى سحبهم
الى خارج المستشفى في ساعات نم الليل
وباتوا في العراء وفي الشوارع العامه خوفا
من اقتحام قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي لهذا
المستشفى الذي يعد الاخير من المستشفيات
الرئيسيه التي تعمل في عموم قطاع غزه